[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMRAT RAY: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this talk
about best practices
that we have learned in
Google production security
and how we can apply
them with Istio.
So, the focus for today's--
oh, sorry.
One of the focus for today--
we'll talk about how the
production landscape is
changing, what is its
impact on network security,
and why Google's approach
is actually increasingly
relevant and now more
approachable than ever
for the enterprise.
And Istio is a means
to an end of achieving
a security of purpose, right?
The key thing is to implement a
set of key security principles
that we have learned
over the years
to protect our microservice's
infrastructures within Google's
production.
And that's what we
will talk about.
And I am Samrat Ray.
I'm a Product Manager on Google
Cloud's Security and Privacy
organization.
And my focus is on service
security and insider threat.
With me is Julien Boeuf.
He is a Network Security
Lead for Google's production.
And I think this session
is special in the sense
that you get to hear from
the people who actually build
this stuff, which is Julien,
right, versus the people who
generally talk about it.
So, with that, without
further delays,
I'll hand it over
to Julien to start
explaining how he sees the tech
model evolve over the changing
production needs, and
then talk about how
the principles of Google
production security
that have informed our posture
for over the last decade or so.
JULIEN BOEUF: All right,
thank you very much, Samrat.
And hi, everyone.
So, production infrastructure
is changing, right?
And that has a big
impact on security.
So, we are observing
a number of trends
from our customers
and our partners.
And there are, like,
three major trends
that I want to talk about.
The first trend is the use
of orchestration frameworks
and containers.
And the most popular of these
orchestration frameworks
is Kubernetes today.
The second trend is the use
of hybrid and multi-cloud,
meaning that one workload may
be in one environment on-premise
and can move to another
environment on the cloud
provider.
And the third trend is the
adoption of microservices.
So let's start with
containers and hybrid.
And I will have--
a big claim here
is that IP-based network
security is suboptimal.
So your IP tables
can only go so far.
And why is that?
That's because when
you think about it,
an orchestration framework is
going to schedule containers
on a pool of hosts, right?
And the orchestration
framework can kill the workload
on the host, reschedule
that on another host,
and as a consequence, the IP
and the host IP in particular
doesn't have a lot of
relevance anymore, right?
These containers, also these
workloads-- they're ephemeral.
They can be started and
stopped very quickly.
Now for hybrid, as
I said, you will
have a workload that starts
on an environment on-premise.
And then that moves to another
environment which is cloud.
And when that occurs,
you don't want
to have to reprogram
all your network
policies because the subnet
is not the same, right?
And so what that
means is that we
need policies and access logs.
Like, policies and
access logs-- they
need to have a stable
identifier for the workload.
The other trend
is microservices.
And when you think about your
old monolithic application
where everything was
integrated in one big binary,
that monolith got exploded
into a constellation
of microservices.
And as a consequence, calls--
a function call that
used to be local--
are now completely
distributed over the network.
And what that means in
terms of network security
is that your network is
much more privileged now
if you don't do anything about
it, meaning that somebody who
has a privileged
stance on the network
is able to do-- be able to do
much more damage than before.
So we need a solution for that.
The other point that I want
to make around microservices
is that they expose a
lot of different methods.
And let's take an example of
a key distribution service,
for example.
This key distribution
service is going
to expose the methods that
have very different security
properties.
One, method call can be
completely innocuous,
such as a health check.
You want to check whether
the service is dead or alive.
And you will have another
call that is going
to be rotate the master key.
And this one needs to be
really heavily protected.
And again, what this
means is that the policies
need to be able to reason
about these different methods
and the different
levels of privilege.
So that means that the
policies have to go way
beyond layer 3 and layer 4.
They have to operate at layer 7.
So the good news
here to some extent
is that adoption of
containerized workloads
and microservices-- that's
what Google has been
doing for the last 10 years.
We've been doing
that over a decade.
And we have in
production millions
of microservices endpoints.
And so we're informing our
network security posture
by a set of principles.
And I'm going to talk
about these principles now.
So, I'm going to start
this part of the talk
by a quote from Niels Provos.
Niels used to be our
security horizontal lead.
And he gave a talk on production
security in this very forum
a couple of years ago.
And at the time, he
said, "At Google,
we are not pursuing a
hardshell perimeter model.
Instead, we're really focused
on pervasive defense in depth."
There's another
term that you may
have heard about pervasive
defense in depth.
And it's zero-trust security.
So personally, I'm not a big
fan of zero-trust security
because at the end
of the day, you
have to trust something,
or a set of things, right?
If you go with an
identity-based system,
you will have to trust
your identity provider,
your identity issuing system.
You will have to
trust your network
for availability in any case.
So I prefer the term "defense
in depth," which I think
is more correct.
And you can see defense in
depth along a set of dimensions.
And a first dimension may
be how to build your stock
on a production machine from
the hardware [INAUDIBLE] trust
to a bootloader to an
operating system to containers
and applications.
And how do you make sure
that, at each layer,
what you're running is
what you think is running
that's not malicious code?
And that's one type--
one dimension of
defense in depth.
The other type of
defense in depth
that we can think about
is along the network path
and how you can have
two layers of security--
one that is at the
edge of the perimeter,
or at the edge of the production
network, and the other that
is inside, within the
production network.
And since we don't have
that much time today,
we're going to focus on the
second one, the network path.
So, the first
principle that we have
is that we need two layers.
So the first layer is that you
have to protect your production
network at the edge, right?
And proxies are the thing
that provide this isolation.
You can see on this
diagram here you have--
our customer is the blue.
And the yellow person as
going through the Google front
end in order to invoke
a service at Google.
This Google front
end is going to do
a bunch of security checks.
And you can see that if an
attacker tries to attack us
here with, for example, a
denial-of-service attack,
we can detect this attack and
we can react appropriately
through aggressive rate
limiting, for example.
Now for workloads that
are within the network,
we ensure that these workloads
cannot arbitrarily egress out
to the internet because that
would be an obvious vector
for exfiltration of data.
So we have perimeter
security here as well.
And even within our
corporate network,
we make sure that in order to
access the production network,
we go through an
administrative proxy.
And you may have heard of
BeyondCorp, which is something
that we are very keen on.
But there are sometimes
some misconceptions
about what BeyondCorp is about.
So, BeyondCorp is
about the fact that
being on the corporate
network per se doesn't just
give you access to the
production network.
There are a bunch
of other signals
that you need to take
into account in order
for you to have access to
some privileged resources
within the production network.
And the things are,
for example, what
is the device from which
you're operating this request
to the production network?
Is it a trusted device?
Is it an untrusted device?
Who is the person who is
authenticated on this device?
Is it a Google employee?
Is it something else, right?
And the admin proxy
is the one that will,
based on all the signal and the
type of resource that you want
to access in the
production network,
make the decision as to whether
you can or cannot access
the resource in question.
But the thing that I
want to tell you here
is that you don't
stop there, right?
You don't stop at the perimeter.
Within the production
network, you
have to protect your
workloads for all the reasons
that we talked about before
with respect to microservices,
for example.
So how do we do that?
The first thing that
we do is that we
use credentials-backed
identities for all the entities
on the network.
And the entities are the
administrators, the machines,
and the workloads.
And let me talk
to you about ALTS
because ALTS is Application
Layer Transport Security.
It's also known as loas.
And that is the system that we
use to do this type of thing.
So, ALTS does two main things.
The first thing that it does
is that it provisions, rotates,
and revokes all the
credentials for all
these different entities.
That's the first
thing that it does.
But ALTS is also a
transport security protocol,
meaning that it's extremely
similar to mutual TLS
and it's certificate-based
and private-key-based.
So now let's see how Alice, who
is a site reliability engineer,
can schedule a workload,
which is Doodle front
end on the production machine.
So the first thing
that Alice does
is that Alice makes a request
to the Borg Master, which
is our scheduler, or our main
scheduler, for workloads.
And she gives a description of
the Doodle front end workload.
And she also says,
I want this workload
to run as the Doodle
front end identity.
And she does that over on
ALTS, which will reauthenticate
the channel.
Once the Borg Master
receives this request,
the Borg Master is going
to do two types of checks.
The first check is
going to be, does Alice
have the right to start a
workload as the Doodle front
end identity?
The first thing, right?
Can she act as this identity?
And the second check that is
going to be done is that, oh,
but this workload comes with a
configuration about the binary
that I'm going to be running.
And do we have some information
about the provenance
of this binary?
And that's called
binary authorization.
Once these two
checks are cleared,
the Borg Master will then
choose a production machine,
a worker machine on
yellow here, and will,
through an ALTS channel
again-- that is what we have
authenticated and encrypted--
send the configuration
to the production machine
of Doodle front end along with
the credentials for Doodle
front end.
And now Doodle front
end can authenticate
to any of the other entities
that we described before.
For example, Doodle
front end is going
to authenticate to
another workload, which
is going to be Doodle back end,
through, again, an ALTS, which
we reauthenticate the channel.
And from the Doodle
back end standpoint,
Doodle front end
is going to appear
as the client-authenticated
entity.
Another principle
that we have is
to use channel-bound credentials
for authenticating services
within the production network.
So what is a channel?
You can see the channel
as a TLS session
between a client and a server.
And by channel-bound,
what I mean
is that the proof
of authentication
is only relevant within the
context of this channel.
So, authentication credentials
can be of two forms.
One can be certificate
and private keys,
and the other can
be bearer tokens.
And you can see on the
web that bearer tokens
are pretty popular.
But we view strongly
that they are
the wrong choice
for authenticating
within your infrastructure.
Why is that?
It's that basically bearer
tokens, by their very nature,
can be replayed.
And that is a big issue here
because you have Doodle front
end on one end wanting
to talk to Doodle back
end on the other end.
But that's not the only channel
of communication that exists.
Doodle front end
is going to talk
to a bunch of different
other services,
such as the load reporting
service or the log service
or the name resolution service.
And, when that happens, you
don't want the load reporting
service or any of
the services to be
able to replay the bearer
token of Doodle front end
to Doodle back end--
in other terms, to impersonate
Doodle front end to the--
sorry, to impersonate Doodle
front end to Doodle back end.
And what that means
is that we really
want channel-bound credentials.
And so again, for in
Google production,
we use ALTS, which
is certificate- and
private-key-based.
And that doesn't suffer
from this big drawback
of bearer tokens.
Another principle
is that you have
to be able to grant access
based on multiple identities.
And that's not
something that you
can do with, again, policies
just at the layer 3 and layer
4.
Each service, each workload,
exposes methods and sometimes
user data.
And all this access might
be explicitly authorized
by policies.
Now let's talk about
the different identities
that we have here on the
network on the request path.
You first have the workload
identities or service identity
or channel identities
or peer identities.
All these things
are the same thing.
And these are ingress, front
end, back end, health service.
These are the identities that
I talked about previously.
But at the beginning
of the request,
you also have another identity,
which is the original requester
identity.
And that can be, for example,
Bob checking his Gmail
on his phone.
And it's very important for
this original requester identity
to be forwarded along the chain
from ingress to the database
because, at the
end of the chain,
it's Bob's data that we want
to retrieve from the database.
And let's see how this
can work hand-in-hand
with the three identities.
Along the chain,
each workload can
decide which peer
identities are allowed
to present such original
requester identities.
And here, for example, from
the database point of view,
the database can say,
hey, it's perfectly
legitimate for the
back end to present me
with an original
requester identity.
But with health service, which
is just there to make sure
that I'm alive--
this one is certainly not
privileged to present me
with an end user identity.
The first principle-- which
is going to be the last here,
and that's probably the
most important one--
is that your platform must
implement security by default.
And if you see
this diagram here,
you have what is provided
by the platform, which
is at the bottom, and
the application logic,
which is at the top.
The platform supplies service A
and service B with credentials,
with an identity, automatically
without the application
having to think about it--
without the
application ever having
to think about that,
you know, there's
some magic key
distribution going on here.
It just happens.
When A wants to call the
get_info() method on B, again,
just by virtue of using
the RPC framework,
automatically a
channel is created--
a mutually authenticated
channel that
will now say that the caller
is A service and the callee
is B service.
And the service orders are
going to be able to configure
some authorization checks here.
For example, service B can say,
identity A service can access
B.get_info().
And since this is the
case here, the call
is going to be
able to go through.
But again, all this happens
at the platform level
without the involvement
of the application logic.
And that's really important.
Now, there may be some
types of authorization
that really need some context
from the request itself.
And such applications
are typically
heavily multi-tenants.
So if you want an example,
you can think of a file
or directory service, right?
Depending on the path
that is in the request,
you will want to apply
one type of authorization
versus another type
of authorization
depending on the path.
But even for these types
of application-driven
authorization checks,
fine-grained access,
we want to provide
frameworks for that.
And internally, Google
IM is a good way--
a good framework
for achieving this.
So let's recap here
the five principles
that we talked about.
So the first one is protect
your network at the edge.
Second one is to use
credentials-backed identities
for all the entities
on the network.
The third one is to use
channel-bound credentials
for authenticating services.
Four, to grant access based
on multiple identities
if this is applicable.
You don't always have
multiple identities.
But if you do, you need to
grant access based on that.
And the fifth one, and the
most important one again,
is that the platform
implements security by default.
And I cannot stress that enough.
If there's one thing that
I want you to take away
from this talk, is the role
of the platform for security.
Like, don't let each team
of in your organization
reinvent the wheel--
reinvent its own framework.
Settle on one thing and
make it better over time.
So, Istio security
has been informed
by all these principles.
And now Samrat will tell
you how these principles
are being implemented in Istio.
SAMRAT RAY: Thank you, Julien.
So, Julien outlaid some
very important principles
about how we at Google
protect our production
environment against some fairly
sophisticated attacks, right?
And increasingly, we find as
enterprises get more digitized
and move to cloud
platforms, enterprises
are exposed to similar
sort of threats
that Google has been
exposed to over the years.
And we feel that it's
increasingly irrelevant
that enterprises adopt
such principles to protect
their own production
environment.
However, one of the big
challenges here is--
I'm sure all of you realize
what Julien presented was
technically complex, right?
It's non-trivial to
do this in any shape
or form in an enterprise
environment, right?
And one of the
things immediately
that strikes you when
Julien presents something
like this was that, how does
this apply to my production
environment?
It doesn't look anything like
Google's production environment
at all, right?
The problem is not hundreds
of millions of endpoints.
It's not scale.
The problem is
heterogeneity, right?
I have different workloads
from different generations
using different protocols
using different languages,
all sitting within
my data center.
There is no uniform
deployment model, right?
They're across different
kinds of run times.
There is no standard application
framework like the kind Julian
described, right?
Because it's been
acquired over time
across various third-party
software in many cases.
So this new security approach,
which was described elegantly,
is actually very
technically complex
to roll out in my
environment, right?
And lastly, even if I do
attempt to roll it out,
how do I ensure the
success of this?
How do I measure this?
How do I get a visibility in
such a complex environment
as how to achieve this?
And as a product manager,
these are the kind
of problems we landed
up thinking about as to,
like, how do we
make what is really
necessary from a security
perspective much more
accessible to the
enterprise customer?
And with that is how we started
thinking about this problem.
We didn't start
thinking about saying,
we want to build security
features for Istio.
Actually, we weren't
even thinking about Istio
when we started off
with this problem.
We wanted to make these security
principles and this posture
more approachable, right?
And we started to think
about how we can do that.
And it is over time and
looking at this problem
in an incremental manner that we
realized that having something
like Istio is very important
to enable enterprises to be
able to adopt these principles.
So, let's talk
about the primitives
that build up to form Istio
and make this possible, right?
The first thing
that you need to do,
given your heterogeneous
infrastructure and the fact
that you have all kinds of
protocols and languages,
is the ability to virtualize
this application network
endpoint, right?
And Envoy as a
sidecar was something
that our senior technical
leads did a long evaluation
across a bunch of models,
and they came up and said,
this is the most optimal way
of achieving this goal, right?
And so, that gives
us this abstraction.
In addition to-- so, a key
thing about that abstraction
is now you can start being
transparent to your application
code, because this now becomes
your policy enforcement point
and as well as policy monitoring
and network monitoring
point, right?
So now you suddenly
have something
that is the equivalent
of a NIC card,
but at the application
level that gives you
all these properties, right?
Another key feature which
we did invest in in Envoy
was to make sure that
the TCP support was
more robust because this is
one of the key things that
differentiates a homogeneous
infrastructure that's
all RESTful to something that
is more enterprise-like, right?
And so with this in
place, you can now
have uniform policy enforcement
and you can have uniform access
metrics and logs.
The second question you might
ask is, I get the value Envoy.
I get the value
of having a proxy.
But why do I need
a service mesh?
What is the service mesh?
I know I have a mess in
my production environment.
Do I really need a
mesh on top of that?
So it's-- yeah, the name "mesh"
a bit of a marketing play,
right?
What it really is is
a way to virtualize
your network at the application
level to some extent, right?
And in order to do
that, you actually
need, just like with any
other networking software,
or you need a
control plane, right?
And you need a
control plane that can
scale to thousands of services.
And just like any other
networking system,
you need to have a
central policy control
or central policy visibility.
And you need a way
to have a notion
of being able to reason about
who's talking to whom, right?
And you're able to do that at
the L3 level with your tools.
And you must be able to do
that at this level, right?
And how do you achieve that?
The proxies by themselves
are not enough, right?
And Istio really solves
for those problems.
So we chose Istio not
because it's a cool thing,
but because it actually
solves the real problem
from a security perspective.
So going forward, Istio does
more than just security,
obviously, for those who
are familiar with it.
It does traffic management
like load balancing,
as well as things like
ability to route with layer
7 semantics.
Of course, it does security, and
we'll deep dive into that today
a little bit more.
And it does telemetry,
which allows
you to get various kinds
of signals on performance
and error rates to make
sure that your services are
more reliable and performant.
So we'll go back and look
at those five principles
and how you can apply them
using the technologies that we
provide on Google
Cloud into Istio.
So the first is about
protecting your VPC.
In the context of cloud,
your production environment
can be represented
as a VPC, right?
And how do you protect
that at the edge?
There are two main
things to achieve here.
There are two things to do here.
One is to protect your
public-facing endpoints, right,
and protect them against
internet-based threats.
So we provide a couple
of technologies there
which are very powerful.
One is Cloud Armor.
Julien talked about
DDoS protection.
Cloud Armor allows you to--
it's sort of a sophisticated
WAF, which also has DDoS
protection baked in, right?
So this is a critical piece
of your front-end strategy.
The second is--
Julien talked a bit about
how we have an admin proxy
to allow BeyondCorp-like
principles in order
to grant access for our
employees to gain access
to production systems.
We have built a corresponding
thing called Identity-Aware
Proxy, which allows you such--
it's a good way to allow
humans and to secure
human-based access to the
production environment.
Having protected the front end,
you think of the perimeter.
Actually, the
perimeter is not just
what's facing the internet.
In many cases, your perimeter
may be a departmental boundary
that you wish to draw within
your network sometimes.
Or in Kubernetes landscape,
we call those clusters
or namespaces, right?
In your other environments,
you might call it
a network segment.
You need to protect that against
other parts of your network
that don't have the same
level of security sensitivity.
So this internal
segmentation is also needed.
And it still ingresses
a solution for that
because it can act both as a
layer 4 as well as a layer 7,
sort of a proxy in
order to segment
two different pieces
of your infrastructure.
And then, once you have
this front end protected,
you need to now seal out
the perimeter, right?
And that means defending
against exfiltration vectors
and control.
So one of the things we provide
is our firewall policies.
Like, these are layer 3
policies to understand
the out-- we need to be able to
control outbound communication
from within your network.
And now, with what
is just GA, is
VPC Service Controls,
which is a way
to extend this notion
of a secure perimeter
to multi-tenancy cloud
services like GCS and BigQuery
so that you can implement
a similar perimeter
strategy for those as well.
So, this is a diagrammatic
view of what I just
talked about, all right?
So as you can see here,
from a corporate network,
you can gain access to
the Identity-Aware Proxy.
You have Cloud Armor in front.
And these are actually
implemented on Google Cloud's
load balancer.
So they are effectively
policy engine--
both Identity-Aware
Proxy and Cloud Armor
on Google Cloud load
balancer, right?
Additionally, you can now
implement an Istio ingress
that sits right
behind it to provide
additional segmentation.
So, let's take the
second principle,
using credentials-backed
identities
for all entities
on your network.
Now, Julien talked
about having ALTS
as being the source
of truth to provide,
and the certificate manager
to provide identities
to everything-- administrators,
hosts, and workloads.
In your enterprise,
typically it's
very hard to have this kind of
a uniform way of meaning trust.
It's that assigning trust
to users and to hosts
is typically a solved problem
in most production environments.
You have doing this
for many years, right?
What is really unsolved
as a problem is a way
to assign identities in a
secure manner to the workloads.
So this is what Istio
is trying to solve.
It tries to complement
what you already have
and add to that by providing
a certificate of authority
for workloads, which is
different from necessarily
the roots of trust that you
might use to, say, identify
your users, which might
be an Active Directory,
or identify your host, which
in this particular example,
that could be the
Kubernetes master, which
is able to determine the
trustworthiness of a node
on which it is deployed.
So, in this particular example,
taking the same example
that Julien gave but now
applying it to Kubernetes,
you have Alice, who is on a
corporate workstation trying
to deploy a pod to a
Kubernetes cluster, right?
In this particular case, Alice
authenticates to the master
and perhaps as a
particular namespace
admin with deployment privileges
in order to be able to deploy.
So therefore, we know she has
the right privileges in order
to start the Doodle dot
front end over here, right?
At this point, once
she is authenticated,
the master can then deploy
the Doodle front end.
And it assigns an
identity which we
call a service account, right?
So service accounts are now
becoming a common parlance.
It's used in Google
Cloud Platform, in AWS,
in Kubernetes.
They basically represent an
identity that is typically
associated with the workload.
So at this point, once it's
deployed, if this workload were
to be part of an
Istio-enabled environment,
then there is a node
manager which is running on,
that particular
node that then is
able to use this identity that
was just issued by the master
and create a CSR, or
a certificate request,
to the service mesh
certificate authority, right?
And the service mesh certificate
authority now takes this
identity and encodes it into a
X.509 credential that is then
placed--
that is provided to Doodle
front end for authentication.
Traditional X.509 certificate
authenticated hosts.
So we worked with the
open source community
to come up with a way
that everybody agrees on--
at least within the
open source community--
of encoding a workload identity
into an X.509 certificate.
This is called SPIFFE.
And the format that
we all agreed upon
was how it would be
encoded in X.509.
And Istio supports that
and is able to interplay
with any other
party that can also
support the SPIFFE
format for certificates.
Going to the third principle,
using channel-bound credentials
for authenticating services.
Julien touched
upon this lightly.
I will give a concrete example
to make this real, right?
You can, with Istio,
specify a policy
that says, all communications to
service B must be authenticated
over mutual TLS, right?
As in that when we talked
about channel-bound--
I'll cover that one more time--
the identity actually must be
a certificate on the channel,
right, such that identity
cannot be replayed.
So in this particular example,
assuming the shared service,
the logging service
was compromised,
if we are only allowing
mutual TLS-based identities
for authentication, then, even
if service A were to present
its certificate to
the logging service,
the certificate by itself cannot
be replayed because the logging
service cannot
create a channel--
right, a TLS channel--
with the private keys that
correspond to the certificate,
right?
So this is a very key
principle in order
for us to mitigate risk and
escalation of privileges
associated with
impersonation, right?
So that's that all peers-- once
you enable this mutual TLS,
we can guarantee that all
peers are authenticated
using certificates based
on SPIFFE credentials that
are channel-bound.
However, this is easier said
than done for your Brownfield
applications, right?
I imagine a world where you
have an existing service.
You're done on mTLS.
Voila.
Here are some bunch
of phones ringing
because a whole lot of clients
which you didn't know existed
want to enable for mTLS
and they just broke, right?
So it's very hard to
actually do this in practice.
So one of the things
we did in Istio
was to create this mode
called permissive mode.
In the permissive mode, when
you set it to permissive mode,
a server can accept both
mutual-TLS-authenticated
clients as well as regular--
your existing clients.
So that's what we would
recommend for your Brownfield
applications, is you
set all your services
to this permissive
mode, which is now
the default mode for Istio.
And then you ensure
that all your clients
are talking in mTLS.
At some point, you
are able to determine
that all clients
talking to a service
are now mutual TLS enabled.
And, at that point, you
can lock the service down
by tuning it to a strict mode.
We talked about the identity
of origin earlier, right?
And we must be able
to propagate that
as a forwardable
credential, right?
So in this particular,
in the cloud environment,
for example, you
can use identity
of a proxy to authenticate
any human coming
from a portable device.
You can use certain
principles like there's
device type, et cetera,
and authenticating
to Identity-Aware Proxy, right?
So those checks can be done
in order to grant access.
Now, all this context that
is part of the client context
can--
what Identity-Aware
Proxy does is
it encodes it in a token,
which we call RC token.
It's a form of a
JSON Web Token that
has been structured
specifically with great--
we provide greater structure.
And very importantly,
it's a short-lived token.
This reduces insider risk
because if the token is logged
or stolen, there is a sig--
we are reducing the risk by
reducing the time for which it
is valid, right?
Where Istio adds
value in this process
is being able to
authenticate-- or sorry,
be able to validate that this
token is actually a valid token
by contacting the issuer and
validating the fact that it's
a valid token such that the
back end can now safely use
the claims in order
to grant access
or influence business
behavior, right?
And thus, as you
can see, Istio is
taking care of a
lot of the plumbing
that you would normally have to
do in these particular cases.
Going back to the
fourth principle,
which is granting access based
on multiple identities, right?
The main reason to do this
is to protect user data.
So, many of you
might be handling
data of your
customers, and this is
the reason you want to do this.
Not for any other reason.
It's not a traditional
network security posture.
It's more about user
data-- protecting that
through access control.
Let's take this example where
there is a privileged insider--
for example, a support
engineer-- who can access,
based upon real business
requirements, your user data
or your customer data, right?
But what you really want
the support engineer to do
is to only be able to access the
data via the case tool, where
the case tool implements a
lot of your business policies,
like, for example, is that
a valid support ticket
against this, right?
Is the support engineer
properly logged into the system?
Are we logging all accesses?
So on and so forth, right?
If you're able to
bypass this tool,
then you're able to bypass
all those checks, right?
But at the same
time, the case tool
might be a tool
that is delivered
by a bunch of your
developers internally
or a third-party software which
is deployed by somebody else.
The people who deploy--
who have the deployment
privileges in the case tool
need not have
access to the data.
Imagine a financial service is--
or financial records.
The person who
runs a job may not
be an insider to get your
quarterly report, right?
But they have the
admin privileges
to deploy their job, right?
Here, this is an
example in support
that's another example
in the FR kind of world.
So, which means there are
two things that must be true.
The access must come
from the case tool,
and the authenticated user
which it is acting on behalf of
must be a support
engineer, right?
These two things must be true
in order to grant access.
Thus, you have to reason
about both of these identities
in order to grant access such
that this privileged insider
cannot create an unauthorized
client and simply access
because only the user
was authorized or was
on the policy.
Similarly, the case tool cannot
identify itself and, in using
its ambient authority, have
broad access to the data.
Because that's a sure way of
increasing an insider risk,
right?
So therefore, it must be working
under the delegated authority
of a customer support
engineer, right?
And this is a very
key reason why
we need to create yet another
policy engine for Istio
and not simply rely on
existing network policy
unions that exist in
Kubernetes and outside, right?
This is not a solved problem.
Now, it's a new policy
language that we are building.
And we will continue to
work on this over time.
But this is the primary use case
that we are targeting, right?
There's multiple
channels to reach
different users can access for
different use cases, right?
And how do we make
it easy for you
to be able to
build such policies
and implement user
data protection
within your production
environment.
So, we talked a lot
about two identities
and origin identities.
And you might wonder, what about
non-HTTP service interactions
like MySQL, for example.
And the answer is, that's true.
We cannot reason about the
identity at the SQL protocol
level because today, Envoy
doesn't understand it.
Hopefully over time, we want to
increase the number of layer 7
protocols that we understand.
But today, we're
limited to HTTP, GRPC
as the primary protocols
that we support, right?
So in such cases, yes,
we are not able to reason
so strongly about who is
the user on behalf of which
the call is coming from.
But we can still constrain
from which any access can
be presented from.
So for example, even if you
have the MySQL credentials,
you should not be able to access
the database from anywhere
except through service A, right?
And we can enforce
that property, right?
So no matter what--
like, if your MySQL
credentials are stolen
or it was in a source control
system somewhere and somebody
accessed it, they will
still not gain access
because they have to
go through service A.
And that is still
being enforced.
So there's still a VIN of our
TCP communications outside
of where we don't understand
the layer 7 protocol.
The last part is platform
implements security by default.
Throughout this talk,
you might realize
that I've kept talking about how
Istio implements all of these.
I've never said how
your application
needs to change in order to
adopt any of this posture.
All of this complex
technological paradigms
are all expressed
as policies that
get enforced at the
proxy level, right?
So these include encryption
of data in transit.
It includes the
ability to auto-rotate
certain keys-- a
very hard problem,
actually, to do this at
scale and do it properly,
so to ensure that you have the
right cryptographic hygiene.
How do you protect
user data access
by using both identities, right?
This has traditionally
been a hard problem
to enforce consistently across.
And how do you monitor
security posture consistently
across a heterogeneous
environment, right?
Now you have the ability
to do all of that
because you are able to
use something like Istio.
The last point deserves
a little more attention
since I did not cover it before.
And it's important
to understand that--
and in a new world, let's
think of a MapReduce workload
that comes up on a
bunch of containers,
access your sensitive data as
a bad job, and then disappears.
It does a bad job.
You go back, look at your
network flow logs a week later,
a month later,
and try to explain
to internal and external
auditors what just happened.
A bunch of IPs showed up,
contacted this back-end IP.
And then a bunch of
IPs again showed up,
and new IPs that
contacted something else.
And we have no idea
what that IP actually
meant because it's a completely
different workload that
ran in different
points in time, right?
Now you can actually
have logs that has
an identity for that workload,
not of the host, right?
And you're now able to
have this visibility
across a heterogeneous
set of environments,
heterogeneous set of protocols,
including the TCP protocol
which I just explained.
Who accessed the MySQL
database is still
expressible as an identity.
So you're able to do that.
So you're able to
understand that.
And it makes your network
access logs much more meaningful
in this new environment.
And it helps you go through your
security and compliance audits
much more easily, right?
And you're able to do this in
a consistent manner independent
of your infrastructure.
So with that, I would
like to just explain
how you can get started
if this is something
that is of interest to you--
how you can get engaged.
To start with, I would
strongly recommend
that you read our
infrastructure security papers,
and in particular,
the application
transport security
papers so that you
have a deeper understanding
of how this actually works
at a deep technical level.
And then to engage in Istio, you
can start by reading the blogs
and going to our
website, which has
the concepts, a bunch of
examples, and how to get
started in open source.
On Google Cloud,
we have an Istio
on GKE, which just sort
of makes it much more easy
for you to just get started.
So I strongly recommend
that as a way to get
started on a hands-on basis.
If you want to know
more about what
we're doing as Google's
secret sauce around Istio,
please reach out to me at
samratray@google.com, right?
And I'm happy to
help work with you
to give you more information
about what we are doing to make
this much more magical for you.
So, thank you all
for taking the time
and having the patience to go
through a fairly technically
complex topic.
I hope this was a
good use of your time.
And there's a lot of interesting
talks about service mesh
that have happened during Next.
Some have already occurred.
Some are coming up.
Please feel free to attend
those which are coming up.
Or go and look at
the videos for those
which have already
occurred if you
haven't attended them already.
Your feedback is
greatly appreciated.
We don't have a moderator
for the [INAUDIBLE]..
But, if you do ask
questions, we can--
on the [INAUDIBLE],, we
can certainly look at it
and come back to you offline.
In the meanwhile, we have a few
minutes-- like, four minutes.
So if anybody has
a few questions,
we can take a couple
of questions right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]